Will Smith jazz style we missed anyone
Fresh Prince Fresh Prince callback
nostalgia hey guys is it microphone
teeth
I don't know so on OK
it's Ryan right and I'm Jerry we're
gonna watch the red band trailer for the
interview
apparently it's a movie that stars Seth
Rogen and James Franco oh it's this
movie okay controversial comedy you know
people say all the actors lie for a
living but this is living a lie okay Rob
when you're ready get ready Kimber - oh
Jesus [ __ ]
whoa his head looks like how to take you
barely look different Thanks we've been
together for a thousand episode
congratulations on a thousand hours of
being a massive sellout what do you mean
you guys got some pictures just came out
where it looks like McConaughey's
[ __ ] and goat oh go [ __ ] conahey go
[ __ ] did I'm gonna get to go get that go
got some questions that I go every night
millions of people want our show
I just wanted cover actual news not
Nicki Minaj's vagina [ __ ] popping out
of the Grammys you don't like a predator
no new brown sugar look at this
Kim jong-un wants to do an interview
with Dave Skylark he's a fan look at
this but [ __ ] it die in a real story
what is okay
let's [ __ ] do it
mr. Rapoport I'm agent Lacey with
Central Intelligence yo Aaron yo I don't
know what [ __ ] last night but I got some
cake
Oh Dave it's actually yo air does your
dick stick so weird how you like just
want to keep smelling it though Dave
the CIA is here YouTube's going to be in
a room alone with Kim
we got the interview the CIA would love
it if you could take him out hmm take
him out for drinks like today about the
town no take him out you want us to kill
the leader of North Korean name I die
but we be total [ __ ] if we didn't
do this I've had a great life and the
best best friend [ __ ] more women than
Ellen DeGeneres
you must die that's the American Way
that's what you want you have to secure
the payload what we do what we do there
are people coming we're the football
minute we could hire you but one sticker
to buy this you gotta put in your but
right now it's a little big to stick up
is they are closing in on you that could
be secure dad yes Oh [ __ ] weapon of
mass destruction you got [ __ ] by
Robocop dude a good old dancer of
buddies is back I guess you know high
stakes spy comedy I guess so yeah it
looks a little off of funny to me it
looks a little off but overall I'm like
it's the James Franco looks like he's
having a great time I like the other
trailers a lot more than this one
what are you talking about this included
swear words and sex jokes I know it's
very much so but it didn't this looks
like a different movie to me now it
looks like what they normally didn't
realize they were playing characters I
thought they were playing themselves
again I didn't realize they had like a
talk show and they were doing like a TMZ
thing and they were actual characters I
thought this was like Hollywood decided
to send Seth Rogen and James Franco do
not agree had to do this no that's
that's not at all you're you're wrong
yeah I know you're clearly this doesn't
look like it's tight a comedy it tied to
comedy as tight a comedy as tight of a
comedy and um well here's my rebuttal
hmm it still looks funny to me
immediately is funny reviews of me
coming out for and people are liking it
is it yeah I mean out of the way this
trailers paste it just look to me like
this would be one of those movies where
it's pasted weird and like the jokes go
on too long and they're all kind of the
same one sex joke over and over again
it's like Oh James Franco's overly horny
and stuff like that so he's always going
to say something really awkwardly sexual
he doesn't realize other people were
around and then Seth Rogen who's the
straight man has to stick something it
was but a lot
remind you of like you and I a little
bit I guess I am I think you like
triggers I thought we'd relate more it's
okay I don't know saying it looks bad
I'm just saying I'm actually less
excited now that I've seen this trailer
than the other trailer that's
disappointing yeah I know that's a win
oh well yeah some of it looks a little
bit rehashed from previous installments
of these guys you're in this like really
different kind of world but you got
these regular guys who talk about sex
and [ __ ] and like they have their back
and forth but the back-and-forth looks a
little bit off but it could be just the
editing of the trailer it could be yeah
I mean it's weird it's almost seems less
like crazy and daring than the original
trailer I said yeah you know did feel a
little toned down
yeah it's it seemed like they should
show more obscene x' instead of like
actual dialogue see just so they could
get the swear words and sex jokes on
there oh yeah so going I saw the first
chair I was like oh they're doing some
actually looks kind of interesting cool
here you know along the lines of how
committed this is the end was to what it
did and I saw this trailer I was like oh
this looks more just like a standard
comedy now yeah I can't wait for this
movie to prove you wrong I would hope so
I really hope it proves me wrong wow you
just have an optimistic answer for
everything don't you I guess I do
well if you guys are new to the channel
you can subscribe to the rejects you can
as possible and Jerry has a playlist of
[ __ ] that he does yeah reasons to Jerry
possible or as I call reasons -
jerr-bear oh thanks because you got a
Jerry care anything that rhymes with Jer
I immediately do I live in the jail air
yeah you do where's Jerry
well yeah it's like if I made my own
line of you know Jeremiah yeah like like
equipment and clothing it could be
jarowair yeah that's what reasons -
Jerry would mean did we were where the
Jerry m.d. David 9 please can I have a
shout out I watch all your bids and you
never see me guys now that I can see you
yeah I mean
whatever I kind of don't really give a
[ __ ] to be honest I mean I mean who so
what you watch all our videos contribute
the views a subscriber account I mean I
mean cheese what's one out of thirty
three thousand oh whoa singing a
different tune tonight
today you know I want to get drunk with
power more than it's actually going to
happen okay you're just trying to force
power I'm trying to force be drugged
with our losing control Andy Dave and I
you know I like you
and yeah I've replied actually your
comments I know you I know you true as a
matter of fact they give you a shout out
reason I'm looking that's right I
remember now well take two and vote
twice now I have to do three shorter
ones because of you Jevon Lee there's a
shout that is a sure wash out out this
is a question or yeah he wants it he's
having he's questioning me whether or
not he wants to shallow
Jevon Lee um yeah you know what I do
want to show you out meliss Islands
treasure it dark CD me darkside mica
Ryan doesn't want to be captured he
wants to be hunted shout out yes I just
saved me oh because I wasn't in the
trailer reaction for one of them Oh ice
messed up yeah I want to be hunted and
you know what people have been looking
for me for a while but sometimes the
hunter becomes the hunted when you're
coming after this guy that's right
take down these [ __ ] my furnace
is so diverse I've found my home I have
like a lot of dead previous subscribers
good me you know I had to cancel their
accounts after murdering them that's
what this moment yeah I know I can't get
rid of it no matter how much Febreze I
use that's upsetting kinda makes it
worse for breeze isn't exactly a feeling
yeah people just think like I took a
[ __ ] and try to clean it up with it swim
for breeze but that's not true that's
not what dead people spell no what are
you [ __ ] out what are you [ __ ] if it
smells like dead people already get rid
of it I have to eat the dead people so
it's a lot of cannibalism going on here
this is a really dark place you live in
yes it is hmm
just like should see D me cut it we
brought it back dark dark side dark side
dark side are you seedy dark side Myka
Marcello forgot about you instantly you
my friend have a weird looking thumbnail
for colo you sound Italian oh my god
Italian I love the big schlong bigger
this long they get a ding dong that's uh
that's what that means I don't that mean
happy so pre colo means take care of
America and the rest of the world it's a
dog in a police uniform oh it's a dog in
a police uniform or maybe like can't be
happy oh isn't that sadism no unless the
dog just really hates it you keep
forcing upon the dog with this dog isn't
look upset to be honest I'm not even
entirely sure would say doesn't means
well it's like Satyam is like just
enjoying the infliction of pain upon
others like a sadist like Stu enjoys
making people to pay him agree to
disagree
When in Rome